[Music]
[Applause]
Marcellus Wiley part of The Dan Patrick
Podcast Network a weekly show unique
Journey around the sports entertainment
cultural landscape it's called more to
it with Marcellus Wiley you can listen
wherever you get your podcast this week
Marcellus talks about Brittany Greiner
Andrew Luck and why Deion Sanders did
not buy into the BS Marcellus also had
this to say about the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers you know what's crazy about
this this is exactly what the buck
signed up for
they signed up for this when uh Tom
Brady misses 11 days of training camp
when Leonard fournette becomes five net
six net just big and then oh ain't that
big all way the same you try to run that
game on people like the the scale says
the same but let's just say my pants
don't fit the same
the Buccaneers played the Bengals coming
up this weekend
you think this is it for Tom Brady
I don't think this is it just because
Tom Brady can't let this be his last
hurray in the NFL with that greatness
that resume the dynasty the dynasties uh
he was able to create you can't end on
this note and I don't think it's just by
record or the fact that they may make
the playoffs they won't be a Super Bowl
champion team I think it's the fact that
Tom Brady knows that he wasn't all in
this year I think that he doesn't want
his resume his legacy to say I wasn't as
committed at the end as I was throughout
my duration of my career so this is Tom
Brady saying I have to go out there and
play my best and playing my best means
full commitment this year we haven't
seen that and okay you got a divorce
yeah you get your family situated then
maybe that can help him if he wants to
play one more year and and I still look
at Las Vegas
Josh McDaniels you got Devonte you got
Josh Jacobs you got defensive you know
some impact players there I know it's a
tough division but if you see well do
you see a different scenario for Tom
well it looks like Josh is going to
survive this year despite the up and ups
and downs with this team but more
importantly I I don't know if Tom Brady
is in position to map onto a team to win
a Super Bowl I think you got to be a
little more selfish in this moment and
think about your legacy think about what
you want out of the situation obviously
that's the Ultimate Prize uh but that's
it almost impossible calculation to make
a team that looks ready made on paper
typically is not the team that's going
to win the Super Bowl the intangibles
kick in so if I'm Tom Brady as much as
the narrative is everywhere he goes he
wins and wins a Super Bowl the reality
is you just don't want to go out on a
sour note or a note that is not as
committed we saw Brady throw a couple of
interceptions against the Niners Dre
Greenlaw got uh one of those and uh
here's Tom Brady talking about the
defensive player for the Niners asking
for an autograph
it was for me to be honest it was
complete
but I try to be a gentleman no it was
actually he's a yeah I mean look it was
a great play he made I'm happy he's got
the ball I wish I didn't throw it but
I'm trying to be a good sport because a
lot of times I'm not a good sport I
could be a pretty bad sport and say in
the moment when they get me in the right
frame of mind I'm actually good support
all right in your third year
I think you sacked Brett Favre fourth
year you got Tom Brady let's let's go
let's stay with Brett Favre
third year player you sack him
I'd say at the end of the game
you want to get an autograph
football jersey
did you ever do that did you ever ask
for an autograph from somebody that you
defeated
no I never did it just because I didn't
think it was the time or the place uh we
know football is more than just tackling
and running around it's also the
mentality uh they're always your
opponent into this the off season over
there to your teammate right so I I
never bought into that obviously you're
a gentleman handshake how's the family
respect but I will give you one where I
was a fan man uh grew up a John Elway
fan to the fullest uh Eric Dickerson and
John Elway motivated me to play football
and my first game ever in the NFL
preseason was in Denver against John
Elway and I just remember looking at him
five feet away around the 50-yard line
in warm-ups and like that's not the
seven that's that foot locker that's
actually John Elway right there and that
was as close as I got to a fan man and
also as close as I got to Sacramento
what do you what do you think of what
Drake Greenlaw did asking Brady
it's a different world these guys are
they're so immersed in like social media
clicks uh everything is just something
that they can take viral and everything
now is so personalized like I see guys
walking from their car
to the locker room and that's a montage
video doing commercial breaks in the
stadium I'm like everything they do is a
movie so yeah they're actors now they're
not even just like hardcore Primal
Neanderthal football players they're
like in some kind of like third
dimensional movie so yeah the rules are
gone the way I lived you have to get off
the lawn now they all share the same
space he's Marcellus Wiley the former
All Pro defensive and and host to uh of
the podcast more to it Dan Patrick
Podcast Network on the podcast you
talked about Deion Sanders not buying
into the BS
what BS
oh uh the BS is that Deion Sanders has
to do something for others before
himself the BS is that Deion Sanders has
to handcuff him to a situation that is
less served for him just because it's
for the culture when the culture should
be for Deion Sanders and promoting his
growth to the greatest limit it can go
um so the BS is something that I think
we all have faced in certain facets of
our life when maybe it's your
surroundings maybe it's your friend
group when you try to do more and you
remember growing up and you just tell
your friends oh man I'll see y'all later
where you going I'm going to study we
got to test tomorrow oh man and it was
just to improve yourself but they
literally are trying to sway you because
they want you to be bigger for the group
than for yourself so I'm glad Deion
Sanders who I had full confidence in
that this was a stepping stone Jackson
State was a stepping stone to the next
as Colorado will be a stepping stone in
and success to the next so I'm just glad
he didn't buy into the BS narrative
could Brock Purdy be an upgraded
quarterback for the Niners
yes is he is he an upgrade
not yet um I I tell you why the yes is
the talent the yes is the measurables
the yes is the fact that they believe in
him I'm not sold yet because it's one
thing to wake up oh let's start here
it's one thing to get thrown into a game
uh adrenaline rush and you're just like
okay I'ma just play off Instinct it's
another thing to wake up and you're like
okay I'm the starter going forward and
it's another thing when they hang those
Super Bowl expectations on you and it's
playoff time and everyone is not just
saying oh you did well as a fill-in no
we're counting on you so last week was a
fill-in responsibility now it's going to
get in success to where we're counting
on you and so far under Shanahan only
Jimmy G has been the one who has raised
his hand and stood tall in those moments
every other quarterback look at
Shanahan's record what every other
quarterback they faltered in those
situations we are ever on a team where
the backup was better than the starter
at quarterback yeah uh this is gonna
hurt because I still see Rob Johnson
every now and then but uh Doug Flutie
was better than Rob Johnson
um we had that quarterback Civil War in
Buffalo you talking about Crips and
bloods you're talking about dissension
you talk about banging in the locker
room the owner was against Wade Phillips
the head coach uh half the offense was
split defense was sold on Doug Flutie
and all this time we couldn't say
anything to the media or in public we
just had to say moms to work but in
reality we were all sold on Doug Flutie
because we had more success and when he
got his opportunity he showed why we
believed in him but yeah that was crazy
when you got a guy out there and you're
like we got a better one on the bench
coach get with the program yeah if
Flutie was around now
then he could make an impact right that
this would be better this this system
this scenario because now we don't go oh
he's only five nine or five ten uh he he
was Flutie was a great player he was
just too soon he was before his time oh
yeah he would have been Kyler Murray
maybe Kyler Murray Plus in some
situations because Doug Flutie could
play the game he just was stereotyped he
was just looked at and they just said we
gonna box you in as a guy who can't
throw between the tackles and only can
run outside to find vision in space but
Doug Flutie one of the greatest athletes
I've ever been around and I'm talking
about all sports all things Doug Flutie
was a special player but just wasn't
given great opportunities so he always
went to the plate there were two strikes
before he took his first swing and
that's why he didn't get all the flowers
he deserved and she'll like it too
[Laughter]
I love Flutie flakes man he was a beast
um when you have a concussion do you
know you have a concussion
when I played we never said we had
concussions uh my first concussion
happened when I was eight years old in a
swimming pool doving three feet dumb uh
my second concussion was falling off a
swing got pushed out of the swing by
some gangsters they're dumb
um in NFL I didn't have any concussions
we said you got your bell wrong and we
didn't even term it a concussion so I
know that I've blacked out before which
I know now is I had a concussion but all
through my 10 years of playing in the
NFL not one time did anyone ever walk up
to me and as I can remember any of my
teammates say oh you have a concussion
we know guys got knocked out it's just
the terminology was different but what
happened with the Patriots on Monday
night
it's interesting when you see like the
players now there's so many conflicting
interests right uh you have the interest
of the player who doesn't want to
acknowledge the concussion for obvious
reasons playing time money and
opportunity it's the it's the
independent Doctor Who is trying to tell
you from the outside what you are
feeling on the inside it's the team that
is obviously wink wink for the player
but really for the player playing and
all those things are just conflating and
conflicting at one time so it's a crazy
situation to always look at yeah but
you're supposed to have an independent
spotter
correct yeah
but he had to be watching another game
because you have somebody down uh who is
it uh uh Jacoby Myers or DeVante Parker
he's down and they help him up
and and then all of a sudden you're like
he shouldn't be out on the field
but they missed it now yeah if it's a
quarterback we're gonna air to the side
of caution and in that situation they
didn't his teammate had to call timeout
yeah it's crazy you know because one
there was no other game to watch so you
know he was just caught up in the sauce
right and more than that
um when you're in that position
obviously you need someone to save you
from yourself right it's why a boxer has
a corner man is to protect you uh when
you can't go out there and when you
shouldn't be out there and in that
situation they missed it because that
just shows you that the real motivation
is not just players Health it's it's the
bottom line it's the dollars like we
need them out there like you should err
on the side of caution so much that that
can never happen but it does happen and
it happened with Tua Etc it happens
because their hearts not in Saving the
players fully and you know when you talk
big business you can understand why in
that respect but when you're talking
about player safety in one breath it
doesn't make sense always great to talk
to you thank you Marcellus all right
brother talk to you soon Marcellus Wiley
the podcast is more to it and uh great
reaction to uh his opinions not afraid
to talk about uh sensitive topics uh
he'll go where most don't go more to it
with Marcellus Wiley wherever you get
your podcast